- I would get frustrated
with Jay for wanting me to come.
I was like, why can't you just
fuck me and come?
And like, why do you have to
worry about me so much?
- Agreed. Agreed.
- (Jay) Sorry.
- Sometimes I'm like,
I like to be just used
'cause I'm like, I don't even--
I'm gonna come? Yeah, right.
- You hear that, ladies?
Sorry.
Don't worry about it, ladies.
Where's my lens?
Ladies, don't worry about it.
I'm sorry. I just, yeah...
You have to come first,
or it's not gonna happen.
I guess I'm a piece of shit
like that.
♪♪
(fire crackling)
I'll tell you what.
The happiest kids in the world
to me by, uh...
you know, per capita
seems to be these rich kids
who end up in my building
where their parents pay for them
while they go to college...
- To get into college.
- ...to just fucking party...
- Yeah.
- ...in my building.
- Well, see what's crazy about
that is I--
- That's it.
Now there's party-- (stammering)
My building's--
the apartments are expensive.
- It's the best time of life.
- These college kids can do--
But there's five of them living
in an apartment
and they just fuck shit up.
- It's the best.
- And they seem super happy.
- They do seem super happy.
- It's the best time of life.
- They don't seem dark.
- Yeah, but see, like, for me--
the drinking was
a little more sad
'cause I didn't have
any money coming in from family.
So you're just like dead broke.
- No, right.
That's what I'm saying.
when you're genuinely broke...
- You're like, when you're
getting fucked up
because it's like,
sure it's fun,
but also it makes sleeping
on an air mattress
in a windowless room better.
- It really does.
- I didn't get too dark until
my early 30s when you're like,
I think I'm a fuckin'
dark, weird failure.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I think I'm failing at this.
- Isn't that funny?
The 30s is the hangover
of the 20s
where you're just like,
oh, fuck. Oh, goddamn.
I thought that was a great idea.
- Wow.
That's profound.
It really is.
'Cause I look back on my 20s,
I'm like, it was blissful.
I was broke
and, like, not healthy,
and hung over all the time,
but I had the best ti--
I had the best time
getting fucked up.
- Yeah.
- I really, like,
if you're getting
fucked up currently
and still drinking,
I always like to say
just have some fun 'cause
you're gonna get to a place
where you can't do it anymore.
- Yeah.
- And I look back and I'm like,
I had the best time
and I won't ever go back to it,
and it's--
I kind of mourn it.
- I had a brief time.
I have a very brief time
of, like, uh...
- Enjoy it.
- ...drinking heavy
and stuff like that. Yeah,
it was like three years ago.
- (Nikki) Yeah.
- It was, uh, I think it should
been in my teens or early 20s.
- Was it-- Did you have
a great time, though?
- But-- Uh, no, 'cause Christine
was drinking, too,
and she's not that great
when she's drunk.
So it went haywire.
- Yeah. Well, yeah, you don't--
- But that was my only time.
She doesn't drink now at all.
- (Nikki) Yeah.
- But, like, that was my only
time really drinking.
I didn't drink much.
I had my daughter young, though.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just--
- Man, I really lived
hand to mouth for awhile.
- Do you agree with me?
- I was drinking--
Uh, it's fun up until the end.
- Up until it's not fun
and then you quit.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah-yeah.
- The end is awful.
That's why you quit.
- When it stops being
not fun anymore,
it gets awful,
then you're just, like--
- But people who have guilt
over drinking
around me sometimes will be,
like, "I-- Is it weird?"
But they're still having fun
with drinking.
- Yeah.
- It hasn't become a sad thing.
I'm always like, no!
Live it! Be in the moment!
- I watch Bert Kreischer,
and I'm like,
I wish I could drink again.
- That, uh...
- I want to drink with Bert.
He's, like, one of the people
I would want to drink with.
- Yeah, he does have fun.
- There's a real heavy,
heavy documentary about
the guitar player from Korn,
the one guy who left
and came back.
- Yeah.
- But he talks about,
in that documentary,
the lead singer from Korn
said he was one of the first
ones to get sober.
- (Dan) Yeah.
- And he said when he got sober,
they were,
like, worried about,
like, partying around him still
and everything,
and he said--
He was like, "No, I loved it."
He goes, "I used to really enjoy
the act of, like,
"cutting the lines
and everything for everybody.
I would, like, still prep it
for everybody."
- Yeah.
- "I just can't do it,
"but you guys fucking rock out.
"If it's not causing your lives
to fall apart,
go for it."
- And as soon as those people--
like, people get worried
about getting sober
that you're gonna
lose all your friends,
but what happens is you just,
like, see what you thought
you were having fun doing, and
then you kind of see it clearly,
and you're like, oh,
this isn't as fun.
And then you just naturally
don't want to do it.
It's not like you're like,
"I long to have fun
like that again!"
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Do you agree?
- Yeah, I walked by this bar,
and I always used
to romanticize it
from my drinking, like,
my hard drinking days.
And I'm like, it's just such
a great neighborhood scummy bar.
- Yeah.
- And then you walk by now
and you're like, whoa.
- Now you get your joy
watching grown men
in costumes fake fight.
- (Nikki) Oh, my God.
- And that... that's healthy.
- And let me tell ya.
That-- That has no psychological
reprimands at all.
- Dan, find your lens.
- Wrestling... wrestling's
better than drinking.
(laughter)
Pivot.
Move.
Uh, wrestling--
Yeah, dude, I don't know.
My life,
drinking was a lot of fun,
but it was also very destructive
at the same time.
I was just like, you know--
- You were-- it was physically
destroying you.
- Physically destroying me.
- You would have--
If you would've
been drunk at that event
that you're talking about
being joyful at,
that has a bunch of acronyms
I don't care to remember.
- The WWE. Monday Night Raw.
- The WWE...
- If I would have got
hammered last night...
- ...TC, is it another?
- No. WWE Monday Night Raw.
- Oh, okay.
That was where you were at.
- Yeah, I was at Raw last night.
If I would have gotten drunk
last night, that would
have been the best
for the first hour and a half.
- Yes, but then...
- And then I would
have been obnoxious.
- And you wouldn't remember
it... as much.
- Well, again, when I just
always argue
about the drinking thing that
I just don't fully understand,
is the day after the next,
if it's the same thing,
the same mistake...
- Yeah.
- ...day after day, like--
- (Dan) Groundhog Day.
- And it's like Christine has
explained it to me as best
she can, and I don't think
it's a bad explanation,
although, I just don't
get it when she--
I was like, if you know four
drinks is where you get,
like, it's a fun night.
We're having a really fun night.
- Then by the time
you're at three and a half,
and you see four closing in...
- Right.
- ...you're like, I'm gonna get
five, six, and seven.
- And the person that's gonna--
- But-- But here's my thing
what I don't understand is,
but you know for sure,
as last night
and the two before told you,
five and six are the ones
where you puke,
but you're right here,
and still you believe, he goes,
"No, but tonight--"
She's saying that
basically you're saying,
"No, but tonight it's just gonna
maintain that buzz.
- (Nikki) Gonna be different.
Right.
- And I don't understand that.
I'm like, I don't know.
- It's because the person
in your head that's supposed
to stop you at four gets drunk.
- Yeah! That's exactly it.
- Yeah, my mind doesn't do that.
- That is exactly it.
Straight up,
your inside brain is hammered,
and it's like,
go smoke a cigarette,
come back,
have two more.
- "Live your life, dude."
- Yeah. Who do you--
Who do you--
Dude, that's my favorite.
That was my favorite drunk
thought of all time.
It would always be like,
Dude, who's telling you not
to do that?
You should do it.
I think you should
step up and fucking do it.
- Most of my drunks
have been with you.
(Nikki)
Doesn't make any sense.
- Christine, most of my drunks
have been with you.
Have I made you think, though,
like I would say my mind,
like, my brain function
of what should happen next...
- (Dan) Yeah.
- ...does stay sober.
Wouldn't you agree with that?
- Yeah, it's a bizarre thing,
and drinking with Jay was...
- Like, I never-- I never lose--
I would never have a thing--
Like I said, I've never...
I can't wrap my brain
around the idea
if somebody came
up to me and was like,
"Sir, I'm gonna have to
ask you to leave."
I would immediately assume
I am the one
who did something wrong,
and I would be like,
I'm sorry, did I fuck up?
Am I drunk and I fucked u--
That's how I would react--
even if I'm slurring words,
I'd go-- I would assume
it was me.
I would never be
in a place going,
What the fuck?! I don't have to
fucking go anywhere.
- Let me tell you where
drunk Dan would be.
"I can win 'em back."
(laughter)
- Oh, yeah.
- A hammered Dan
would be like--
- I think that would be me, too.
- I'd be like,
"What's your name, man?
Why are we doing this?
What's up? Are you okay?"
- That's a good point.
- "You need to leave.
You want to get a beer?"
- "Listen, who's telling
me not to?"
What was your argument?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna do it because
who's telling me not to do it?
- That doesn't make any sense.
It's such a drunk, like...
- It's such a drunk mantra.
- ...motivational mantra, yeah.
- You know what? I wake up
the same as I went to sleep:
breathing and walking.
(laughter)
Here we go.
Here-- Then I'd wake up
to go work at Dose,
and I'd be like,
I think I'm gonna throw up
and everything is sideways.
- I put my pants on like
everybody else.
Pants on.
- "I go to sleep,
and that's where I dream,
"and when I dream
is when I plan,
and when I plan, I execute."
- Mine's like, "Life is short."
That's always... (stammering)
- Yeah. "Life is short"
is such the
"take another shot."
- It's just "carpe diem,"
"FOMO," like all of that,
just, like, "Why are you?
Just be--"
And that's what I do
with everything in life, though.
Anything I want
to convince myself to do,
I just go, we're gonna--
we're all gonna be dead!
- Yeah! Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It doesn't ma--
Like, everyone who could maybe
judge me for this is gonna die,
and then the people that they
tell are gonna die.
Like, there's gonna be--
- You know how easy it would be
for me to become 500 pounds
in my life
if I lived like that, though?
- (Dan) Oh!
- Who's-- Why would
I not have a--
When I'm on my death bed,
I'm not gonna think about
all the cheese steaks
I didn't eat.
- Yeah! I'll be full
of cheese steaks.
So, I won't think
about cheese cakes.
- Mission accomplished.
(fire crackling)
We were talking earlier
about the-- not on the show,
before the show,
about the things that a guy
will dial back to, if it's not
gonna happen sexually.
I said I've-- When you get
to that point where later,
immediately after you come,
you go, like,
that was ridiculous
that I even asked
for that thing to happen.
But I'm--
So for a good example,
I remember a time
I said I was hookin' up
with a girl,
and I made her come quick,
I think, eating her pussy.
And then, I thought it was time,
and then she had like--
I don't know if it was like,
we shouldn't be doing this or...
- She just like--
her head was clear,
and then she was like, um,
I don't like you.
- The same thing, whatever
it was, but she was like--
- Not you, but you know,
I've been there.
- Whatever it was, she didn't
want to do the thing,
and it was... when you
dial back and you're like,
will you just do the--
And she's like, I guess,
you know, you could jerk off
if you want, and then you'll
be doing that.
It's like-- And then you start
making the negotiating.
"Can I just see a tittie?
Can you grab the base
or something?"
Just the things people
ask for...
- "If I rub my cock
against your calf,
"is that cool?
Just like your--
"would you just shame me
if I just want
like two or three
little magic wands?"
- I would nev-- I'm not
into feet a little bit,
but if a girl goes, "The only
thing that's gonna happen,
"and you have a rager
and I've already come?
You can fuck my toes,"
I'd think about fucking
those toes.
And I don't give
a shit about feet.
- If she was like, "You can
TSA wand me with your boner."
(laughter)
I'd be like, yes!
Yes!
- And then you tap it on
her hip and you go,
"What's this here?
Keys?"
- And she goes, "You're not
moving today, boss."
I go "All right"
and keep moving.
- Why were you in a relationship
with a girl who didn't want to--
- That was-- No, I don't think
these are ever relationships.
- Oh, this is just a girl,
yeah, yeah,
you made come and then--
- My example was--
- I don't relate to coming
right away with a guy.
I just don't relate to that
in a hookup.
And then I also
don't relate to me--
like, I have this sense of
obligation to make a guy come
that I would-- I don't relate
at all to being like, ugh.
I mean, I definitely have been--
- That's great.
I love the devotion,
it's like,
Don't you understand?
She's the best!
She's like Rambo.
She has one mission!
- Yeah...
- To make a man come!
- And even if you were like,
Can I jerk off?
I'd be like, yeah, that's awe--
I don't have to do anything?
You just want to jerk off on me?
Great! Like, that is--
or just--
- But you've never been
approached for that,
because you wouldn't
make a guy
just jerk off
in front of you.
- I mean,
there have been times
where I've hooked up with a guy
recently where I'm like,
you have not earned me
to touch your dick in any way.
You've done nothing to me,
and they wanna come,
and I know that they're not
gonna be able to make me come,
and so we're kind of just
at a stalemate
where they're like,
touch my dick!
- Why do you know they can't--
you can't with a new person
right away?
- Because they're fingering me
and it's worthless.
And they're just--
there's so--
- Overhand?
- There's not enough coaching
that is gonna--
it's just--
They're not saying
the right things.
I'm already just--
(stammering)
- What's the most coaching
with a fingering
you'll hang in there for?
I've made this joke--
(Dan)
Do they have to show form?
- I've made the joke
on stage so much
about a guy fingering
overhand...
(Nikki)
They've just gotta say
some hot shit.
- ...where most girls say
lots of guys
think they go in
overhand fingering.
- No way.
- It's very bizarre.
- Uppercuts, for knockouts.
- Uppercuts.
- Of course upper-- shallow!
By the way,
shallow uppercuts.
- Yes. Yes.
- (vocally clicking)
- And--
- Give it a little Terminator.
- But this guy was already
fingering
before I was even
wanting it, I think.
- Problem is,
you hit that shallow--
you hit the shallow uppercuts,
the problem is, afterwards?
You might be jerking off
to a tit.
(laughter)
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good point.
- Have you ever--
- If you do too well.
- Has a man ever made you came,
and then you're like,
Well, we're good here.
- No. No.
- Okay.
(fire crackling)
- But, I will say I've been
in that predicament
of like, I don't want
to touch your dick.
I'm not gonna blow you,
'cause you haven't earned it.
You-- you're just--
you're not--
But I do want you to come
because I want you
to have a good experience
and your dick is hard,
and I don't want to leave you
feeling unsatisfied.
And, I want to have like
a fun, weird sexual experience.
So I'll be like, just jerk off,
I'll watch, or whatever, or--
- Man, is that hot
until you come.
- Recently--
- And then you're like...
(sighs)
So...
- You're like,
I was a total asshole here.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you just come
and you're like, fuck.
- No, I don't think it's--
I think guys are weird
about it now
becaue of all
the Louis stuff.
Like, oh, I don't want
to jerk off in front of a girl,
that's weird.
I'm like, no, it's awesome.
- Do you think before that,
they were like,
are you gonna come and you go,
do I get an FX show?
- Yeah. Not unwanted,
but if I ask you to, that's--
it's hot.
It can be so hot.
And-- so this guy,
in particular,
so we were like,
we were makin' out and stuff.
I knew that he was not
even gonna do anything to me
that would make me come.
- How did you know that?
- Because, um, he wasn't saying
the right things, he wasn't--
- Jacob's taking notes so
he can keyword search all this
for a jazz session later.
- Jacob goes, did he walk
with his shoulders back?
- (laughing)
- I like that. (chuckles)
Nikki--
I like that Nikki cases it--
- Did he have the posture
of a gentleman?
- I like that Nikki cases it--
like, cases dudes like,
you know,
like she knows, like,
how to like pick pockets,
you know.
She goes, I could tell
by the way he walked,
he had a heavy wallet.
She goes, walkin' in,
I knew I was dry.
I was gonna be dry
for the whole night.
Bring back
my old-timey music, Lou.
We're gonna start talkin'
like this again.
- He just didn't...
like me enough to give a shit.
You know, like,
he just wanted to come.
That was what this was about.
- So you felt that was just--
- I just knew-- yeah.
And I just didn't--
- And you still feel obligation
to have them come?
- I didn't want him--
in this particular instance,
I didn't care
if he came or not,
but I was gonna get something,
a story, out of it.
- Sure.
- Or at least like--
just something weird sexually,
'cause I like to be
a little bit deviant sometimes
and throw my--
and I'm sober,
and so it's hard for me
to be as deviant as
I used to be.
- Yeah.
- And so, it was like--
I was in, like, a leotard.
It's a long story, but I--
- Original dance moves?
Did you guys--
- Jacob says...
details, please.
- Go forward. Is there
a plié barre in the room?
- We were in a trailer...
- I'm gonna lose my shit.
- ...and, like daytime.
Hooking up.
Wasn't-- I wasn't--
it wasn't-- it was like--
maybe I wasn't
gonna come because
I was, like, not comfortable
because a P.A...
- Yeah.
- ...could have walked in,
or-- you know what I mean?
- True.
- It was like that
kind of thing.
- A knock on a trailer is
a real boner killer.
- And he was just like plea--
can you do-- what are you--
And I don't even know that
he wanted me to do anything,
but I decided--
I didn't even want
to jerk him off
through his pants.
Like, he didn't deserve
my hand, I felt.
- Okay.
- I don't know why.
And also, I just don't feel
that confident
in hand jobs.
- In hands?
- So, I think I also avoid them
because I'm just like--
- Good for you.
- (Dan) Christine, what's your--
- Better to be, uh...
- I know what I'm good at.
- ...to be not self-confident.
Yeah, if you're better--
don't think you're good at it,
'cause a bad one will make ya...
- Yeah, I just--
- You don't wanna
fumble around with it.
Fumble the ball right when
you get it, so to speak.
- I legit...
- Ooh-fa!
- ...just took my--
I was straddling him,
and I just, like, went like this
with my shin.
Like, I just kind of like--
- Oh, my God!
You did the calf move
I was joking about?
- I'm not joking, though.
I did that.
And he didn't come,
but it was kind of hot.
And funny.
- It's skin on skin.
- It wasn't even his skin,
it was through his boxers,
but I just did that
for awhile.
- Were they Umbros?
Any chance of Umbros?
- Oh, we were talkin' Umbros
in a couple weeks.
- Oh, Umbros!
- We were saying those--
that's-- those are the shorts
for those.
- Those are coming back.
- That's the--
If a girl shin-fucked me...
- Yes!
- ...in my Umbros,
I'd be like, keep going.
- Oh, yeah, that's a great
hand job or out-- yeah.
- Over the pants hand-- yeah.
- Outside panting.
That's a great fabric for that.
- Oh, it's the perfect one.
- And old Italian man jumpsuits.
- Yes. Suede.
- That's just-- (laughing)
- Suede is--
- Suede?
- I don't know, it's warm.
- Suede will rip your goddamn
dick skin off. Suede?
- Suede. Suede's soft.
- For women, it's like, um...
the best thing
to get fingered through,
Christine? Like, denim...
- Basketball shorts.
- Best thing
to get fingered through?
Christine is gonna answer,
her pussy.
I, uh, you can finger
right through it.
- Like, you don't want it to,
like, soak through,
because you're gonna get wet
so you want it to be
a little bit, like,
of a coarser mater--
like a corduroy?
- (Dan) All right.
- I don't know if I've ever just
done over the pants stuff.
- Oh, I love it!
- (Jay) Hey.
While you girls
are syncing up periods,
Dan thinks it would be okay
to get jacked off with suede.
And he's arguing
that it's a soft material
that would feel good
on your dick.
It will not!
- I think it could.
- It will not.
It will rip your dick off, Dan!
It's like jerking off with
a baseball mitt, you psycho.
- But you need suede that like
changes color when you,
like, rub your hand across it.
- Oh!
- You're talkin' about velvet.
I think you're both talking
about velvet.
- I mean velvet.
- Velvet!
- Oh, I'm sorry, I got--
I got gator cock!
(laughter)
It's all coarse and hard!
- Jesus, fuck, what is happening
to your dick?
- You guys don't jerk off--
- You are from Colorado!
- Okay, we call that
a little Fort Collins handy.
- He goes, I'm gonna go
jerk off.
Pass me my naugahyde!
- (laughing) You guys got
some raw leather?
- My friend, Andrew Collin--
- Oh, never mind.
- There you go, Dan.
Fuckin' wrap that around
your dick, dude.
(laughter)
Why don't you give yourself
a good beat-- why don't you
stick your dick between those
two suede flaps and pump away?
- I'm an idiot.
I'm an idiot.
- You're gonna rip
your pee hole open!
- Is there anything to this?
My friend, the guy
who comes out
on the road with me,
he's on my show all the time,
Andrew Collin, he, um...
he thinks-- he needs--
He's jerked off with his hand
for so long,
'cause he's been single that--
and dry.
He doesn't, like, use lube.
So, like...
- Me, either.
- Now he's having sex and stuff.
- What?
- And he's like,
"It's all too wet.
Like, I can't..."
- What?
- "I need more...
I need drier vaginas."
- This is cra-- first off...
- Does that make any sense?
Because guys really--
- You dry jerk?
- I dry jerk, yes.
- Okay, wow.
We're on to something.
- What?
- This is opening up
a whole new thing.
- That's-- that's real--
- What do you use?
- Uh, lotion or lube.
- I mean, to--
to pull out lube to jerk off
is downright ridiculous.
- Why is it ridiculous?
It's awesome.
- It's ridiculous.
- Why would you do that?
Maybe I want to treat myself.
- Lube? Like, a brand of lube?
- Like a little, like,
warming jelly.
(laughter)
I got a tube of it.
- That's so cute
that you treat yourself right.
- Yeah.
I got a tube of it at CVS
on the road.
I was like,
I'm gonna beat to this.
- You have an English
breakfast tea next to you?
- Sleepytime Tea.
- I do some English
bran muffins in the morning
and I have a nice lubed jerk.
Why not, dude?
I found it at the CVS.
- No, you absolutely should.
- It's a good hotel jerk.
It's like a treat.
- You bring it
on the road with you?
- In his little Dopp kit.
- It's a little--
- Yeah, he's got
a little compartment
in the shower hanger
Dopp kit thing.
- That's where I found it.
I found it on the road
when I was at a CVS,
so I was like...
- Do you keep it hooked
on to your bag like it's Purell?
(laughter)
- Yeah, I go through, I go,
you can take a spritz if you--
- Hey, man, I'm gonna
hit the can.
It looks like our flight's
delayed about a half hour.
(spurts)
Ahh.
(laughter)
Sim sala bim.
Here we go.
- You wanna...
you wanna get a nut?
- 'Cause, what do you do?
- You just jerk dry
like a fuckin' old fisherman?
- I fuckin' grab my dork
and I pull on it.
- Yeah, that's--
- No lubrication at all?
- And then, by the way--
of course--
here's what'll happen.
When you're jerking off,
there's gonna be a little sad,
like, you know, the garbage
Indian tear,
and I will-- I will take
the thumb across that
and I'll work that
right around, you know,
the rim of the fuckin' helmet.
- You will use
your own pre-cum as lube.
- Dude, wow.
You're like a person
that has a fresh water well.
Like, that's all you drink.
- I've been judged a lot
for my things--
I said after--
I'm a pretty sexual person
and I'll go for it.
I've had-- someone
was defending me online,
but on The SDR Show one time
I said after--
like, what do you--
when you come, what do you,
like, put it
in the tissues and...
- Yeah.
- ...do all that stuff?
And I go, no, generally
where I jerk off
is in a hotel before
I'm gonna take a shower.
- Okay.
- Or at home, like, you know,
somewhere between,
uh, ten minutes to an hour
before I take a shower.
And I go, no, if it--
generally, it's like--
first of all, it's not--
I'm not blowing, like,
fuckin' porn loads on anything.
- (Nikki) Mm-hmm.
- (Dan) Sure.
- I go, I just kinda
like go like--
I said, I'll wipe it on
my goddamn thigh
and get ready
for the shower and whatever.
Everybody was like, "Oh, man!"
I'm like, who gives a fuck?
- Yeah.
- No. I mean, I've had it...
- Who gives a shit?
- ...all over me,
so that doesn't--
who cares?
- Who cares?
- Yeah.
As a woman that, like, you know,
girls get it all over them.
- Christine's definitely
walked to a store next to me
with cum all over her body
in some way.
- (Nikki) Yes.
- Absolutely.
- I taught English with cum
all over me once.
- Oh, I'm gonna--
Jacob, write that down for me.
- (Dan) Yeah.
- That's going in my spank bank.
- I like that one.
- Yeah.
You taught-- you taught fuckin'
verb "congregate"-- yeah.
(class bell rings)
You taught adjectives
and you had fuckin'
dry cum on you?
- Teaching a summer school
to Korean students,
'cause Korean parents
don't send-- let their kids,
right?
- And they bukkaked you.
- (Dan) Yeah.
- They love that
over in Korea.
- I was on a lunch break
and I came back.
- (accented)
My son tells me
that you smell like cum.
I had-- I had to meet
the teacher who smells like cum.
(Jay, accented)
It's a little bleachy.
- Oh, man.
That's really gross.
I shouldn't have admitted that.
- Man, how did you--
How did you find that out?
When you got home?
- I just rea-- I don't know if
I actually had cum on me,
but I was in circumstances
where I did not shower
after having
a night of filthy sex,
and I would go in to work.
- Awesome.
- And there was one time
on a lunch break
where I gave a guy a hand job,
and I remember going
back to work being like,
I am-- like, I felt--
I had a skip in my step,
'cause I'm like, what a slut.
- Yeah!
- I was like, you are
a fucking whore.
- What a winner!
- Who do you think you are?
You're gonna go teach children
after you just,
like, defi--
let a man defile--
- Touch 'em all in their
little flat faces
with your cum-- with your fu--
- (Nikki) Oh, God.
- With your salty dick hand?
- Yeah.
- Salty dick hand.
- It was fun.
- Oh, dude, there was a waitress
at The Cellar one time
said to me as, like,
joking but dead serious,
and she goes, uh...
Oh, I want to--
I'll telll you her name off-air.
Everyone knows her.
- I know who it is.
- Yeah.
- I already know
who it is by the story.
- She comes over,
like, laughingly and--
and she puts like her hand
over my, like, face and nose.
And I was like, wha--
And she goes, she goes,
"I just jerked a guy off."
And then I could--
when she said that,
the smell kicked in,
we were like,
that is the salt of...
- Yep.
- You had cock salt?
- Oh, I smell it sometimes.
- It's-- it's--
it's spit
and fuckin' dick salt.
- Yeah, cock salt. Cock salt.
- I can smell it.
At the gym, guys will work out
next to me on the treadmill,
and once they start sweating,
like, whatever cum is on them
starts, like, you know,
warming up.
Like essential oils.
(laughter)
And then it just
starts misting through
my section of the gym.
And I'm like,
there is a cum scent.
- Yeah.
- A strong--
a warm cum scent.
- Someone in this town--
someone--
- But it's not just cum.
- Among the eucalyptus towels.
- It's not just cummy,
it's like spitty dick.
(Christine)
It's like dick hands.
- Yes, it smells like
dirty sex.
- Didn't she just walk up
and put her hand on your face
and say, "Smell like dick?"
and start laughing.
- (Nikki) Oh, God.
- I thought that's how it went.
- No, she said to me--
she goes "I just jacked a guy--"
she goes,
"I just jerked off a guy."
- Oh, my God. Oh, God.
- That's so funny.
- Yeah, unmistakable scent.
- I couldn't even be that mad,
it was so funny.
- It's so funny.
- I was like,
I don't know,
I can't get mad at that.
That's fucking hilar--
'cause she's not lying.
It smelled-- I was like, she
definitely jerked off a dude.
- Oh! Instead of shaking
a person's hands
when I've just washed
my hands and they're wet,
I won't go-- I just--
I just jerked a guy off, sorry.
- That's so funny.
- But every guy--
every guy here for sure
has gone to a store also,
conversely, with--
Well, I don't know.
Everybody here
might be naked fuckers.
But I've definitely had, like,
uh, girl juice...
- (Dan) Dude--
- And when you get to the store
and you start seeing, it just
turns white later like...
- Yes!
- Oh yeah, it's like toothpaste!
(Jay)
Like you're drying out
ketamine.
- It's like toothpaste.
It's like tooth-- yeah.
That's so funny.
It's like toothpaste
on the corner of your mouth.
- Yes.
- You don't realize it's there.
- Oh yeah.
- "Did you make a girl come?"
And you go... what?
- Uh-huh.
- Dude, I had one--
- Oh, also having a beard
like this also, you will def--
- (Nikki) Oh my God.
- But just getting to--
going to a store and being like,
just going like,
and just go-- it's just that
it's soaking wet,
is what it is.
Like, oh, wow.
- Dude, I had a funny one
where I-- tha-- when
I worked at KFMA--
shoutout KFMA Day in Tucson.
- Doesn't exist.
- (Dan) It's a real thing.
- It's not even
a real thing at all.
- This girl came
to the radio station,
and I tittyfucked her
in an office, and then...
- Under a Jani Lane
Warrant poster.
- (Nikki laughing)
- (Dan) It was pretty awesome.
- ♪ Got a picture
of your house ♪
- It was under
a Hoobastank poster.
- Hell yeah!
- (Nikki laughing)
- And I came, and we cleaned
it up or whatever.
And I was wearing these,
like, um...
thin khaki shorts.
And I went,
and my post-cum
had just leaked on me.
(fire crackling)
So you could just see, like,
a puddle of cum
like where-- where my, like,
soft dick was or whatever.
And I just walked in,
I was having a conversation
with all these people in, like,
the fucking cafeteria area.
And then I left,
and the girl I was with,
she's like, "I think it looks
like you pissed your pants."
- Yeah.
- And then I was like,
they're gonna know that tha--
oh, goddammit.
Oh, goddammit.
Oh, man, I did not--
- Which is worse.
- Actually, this might
happen to girls...
- (Dan) Piss.
- ...on a-- this might
happen to--
to women on
a much larger level.
Because one of the worst things
too when you fuck,
and as soon as you
finish fucking,
put your underwear back on
as a guy--
- (Dan) Yeah.
- Sometimes later, you don't
realize that your,
like, dick hole
has kinda become, like,
glued to the front of your--
- Yeah. Yeah, that's--
- Ow!
- It's just, like-- it's just,
like, a quick moment,
but when it pulls off,
it's like getting your eyebrow--
It's that one moment
of "ooh!"
- (Nikki) Yeah.
- So I'm saying on a girl level,
it must-- so--
does it ever get,
like, where it's almost like--
where it's just kinda like--
- Dried up in there?
- (Jay) Just wet?
- No, no.
- Not sticks to it?
- No, we stay-- we st--
we keep it damp down there.
- So you guys--
- So I don't think it has
the chance to really...
- You don't papier mache at all?
- No.
- It doesn't dry
and then hook in?
- No.
- (Christine) Well, wouldn't you
take your underwear off
if they got too wet?
- (Nikki) Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, like,
if your underwear gets too wet,
you just, like,
throw 'em in your bag.
- (Dan making whoosh sounds)
- Yep. Do you ever go to--
- Throw 'em in your bag?
Get rid of 'em, ya slob!
What're you keepin 'em for?
- No, wash 'em and fucking
wear 'em again later.
- Yeah, if they-- yeah.
If you get, like, turned on.
Do you ever get tur--
do you ever, like,
talk to a guy
and you don't even realize
you like him
till you go
to the bathroom later
and you're like, whoa,
that was slick.
- Really? That's a thing?
- I swear to God.
- We don't get--
- And I'm, like, whoa,
what happened up there?
And then I go,
oh yeah, that one thing
turned me on for a second.
- That's so funny,
we don't get delayed boners...
- (laughing) Yeah, you don't.
- ...where you're just, like,
you're just, like, in a cab
and you go, whoa, whoa!
I was fuckin'...
- Dan was on fire today, huh?
Dan was m-- I guess he was more
on fire than I knew.
- It's, like, seconds
between the lightning
and the-- the sound.
- Yeah! (laughter)
It's like thunder and lightning?
- You're like, oh,
it's about three miles away
was when I was turned on.
- One thou-- one Mississippi...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- ...two Mississippi.
So 30 minutes ago,
I wanted to fuck him.
- Yes, someone up there said--
- Did we all learn that
from "Poltergeist"?
- Oh, is that where
that got started?
- That's where I heard it
from the first time.
- (Nikki) Oh, interesting.
- It was count the seconds
between, like, you know, if
it's getting further or closer.
- (British accent) My mother
taught me that in a--
- Yeah, I feel like it was
just like a...
- Well, your mother
learned it from "Poltergeist."
- (Nikki) Mmm.
- And she tried to pass it off
like she was a philosopher.
- Stop it.
She was smoking
a cob pipe.
- (laughing)
- She told me--
(British accent)
She told me that astrology
is next to knowing the gods.
- "Dan, I'm gonna give you
the only wisdom I have."
- (Dan) She goes--
- "Count between
the lightning and thunder
and you'll know how close
the storm is."
- Thermos-- for Thermoses,
use either screwdrivers
or rum and Cokes.
- (Jay laughing)
- And lightning.
You can count it.
- Oh, good advice
from your parents--
Do you have to go to break?
- Yeah, we have to take-- we'll
take our last break, though,
and then we get to come back
and go t-- the whole way.
- Well, my dad just
recently called me ab--
Can I just tell this
quick story about...
- (Jay) Mm-hmm, sure.
- ...parent-- parental advice.
- Apparently, until Thursday,
we play by our own rules here.
Then they change the system,
we have to take
hard line commercials.
Jacob says he's terrified.
- Okay, okay.
When I sense that it's urgent,
I'll-- I'll speed it up.
Okay.
- No, no urgency here.
We play by our own rules.
- Well, now I'm just
gonna really
tuck into this thing.
- (Dan) Yeah, NPR it.
- Stretch it out.
We don't have to take
commercial breaks at all.
- NPR this shit.
- Um, you know the girl
that just recently got
into the wrong Uber
and then was murdered?
- Yeah, yeah, down in Carolina?
- (Jay) Mm-hmm.
- Terrible.
- Yeah.
- Um, my dad--
- You didn't have
to disclaimer that.
He goes, "I'm against that..."
- (Dan) Yeah.
- ..."now."
- Honestly, I think that it
was really unfortunate.
I do wanna say,
it's the most unlucky day
of her life and the luckiest day
of that murderer's life.
- He's like...
- That a-- a girl just--
He-- he happens
to be a murderer,
I don't think
he sought her out.
I think he was just
drivin' through town,
a girl got in his car,
and he goes,
"Well, I guess."
- I mean, from his perspective,
he really was like,
"Wh-- I mean,
fate really brought us
together, huh?"
- Yes, I mean,
that's the thing.
You can argue fate for all
these things that y--
are positive in your life.
Like, that's the reason.
But a guy could justify
murdering someone if he's like,
you know, God show me a sign
that I should not mur--
like, if I shouldn't murder,
don't give me a sign.
But if I'm meant to--
In his crazy brain,
boom, there's a sign.
- Well-- yeah.
- Anyway, my dad calls me
the next day and is like,
"You heard about this girl?
You know that I told your mom
that would never happen to you."
I'm like, okay, what's...
"First of all, she was drunk."
Oka-- oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, "but you know better,
you know that--"
My dad's only advice to me
in self-defense against men is
if a man gets you in a car--
and it is good advice--
you gouge his eyes out.
- Nice.
- Just stick your two fingers
as deep as you can into his eyes
because even if
he crashes the car,
you have a better chance
of surviving the crash
than you do
wherever he's taking you.
And it is, like,
statistically accurate.
- That's a smart piece
of advice.
- It is.
- The ol' Glaser Gouge.
- You find the one guy--
- You go right for the eyes.
- You find the one guy whose
eyes that you gouged out,
he was taking you to this,
like, beautiful place
he built for you.
- (Dan) Yeah.
- "I've been in love with you
and I've been
"writing you letters,
and I thought you corresponded.
I am everything you ever wan--"
- That is the problem.
- You go, was he handsome?
You go, when I think about it,
when he had eyes,
he was pretty handsome.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Steel-- steel gray eyes.
- They were!
Crystal blue. Oh, God.
That was the best thing
about him, goddammit.
- And I could-- I could smell
the warm cum on him.
- He's showing you
the seventh la--
the seven-story treehouse
he built you.
Your dream--
- (Nikki) You know what...
- Your dream enchanted
dream house.
- ...I did love the way
he used to look at me.
- Yeah, this is...
(laughter)
- I'll never have that again.
- This is made with
no animal products.
(laughter)
This is all out of the tree
and it's actually...
- This is all
I've ever wanted!
- ...it's good for the tree.
Look, you have your little
joke-writing nook.
- Oh my God!
- I would-- I would show you,
but my eyes are gouged out
'cause your father
is a boxcar man.
- I'm gonna put my hand
on your shoulder.
Can you-- can you walk me
and assist me in the bathroom?
- "Now, Nikki--"
It sounds like--
- Can you tell me when
I'm done wiping, Nikki?
I'm sorry, I know I used to be
very attractive to you.
But now...
- (Dan) It sounds like advice--
- Can you tell me, is there
poop on this paper?
(laughter)
- It sounds like--
it sounds like...
(laughing)
That sounds like Nikki's advice
her dad gave her
over a can of beans
by a campfire in a junkyard.
He goes, "Now, you ever alone
with a man in a car,
"gauge his--
gouge his eyes out.
"He's probably from
the government
or wants something for..."
(laughter)
- I grew up in
a militia, sorry.
- "Are you done with
your pot of beans?"
- Like, when do you go
for the gouge, though?
- Yeah.
- That is the thing.
Like, when do you go--
- I was so many steps ahead,
I'm like, how does this guy
ever find out
when he's done wiping if
he doesn't have
a woman who loves him?
- Y-- yeah, that's a good point.
- You've embarrassed him
the rest of his life
by gouging his eyes out.
Even when he's in-- sitti--
if he goes
to prison for what he's done--
- That's why I'm against
violence against men
who are violent against women.
- Yes, good stance.
- Because he could love you,
ultimately, and why would you
be hurting a man that w--
is doing this out
of love, okay?
- Love. Love.
- So just take it, bitch.
- (Jay) I mean, you've definit--
- Shut your mouth.
- You've definitely heard
the WorldStarHipHop rants of
like, a girl taking
the thing to be like,
"If he don't beat you,
it's 'cause he don't care."
- (Nikki laughing)
- And they mean--
they are so dead--
- I know!
- It's like someone's
telling you flat earth
with, like, a straight face.
- (Nikki) Yeah.
- They go, no--
There's nothing kidding here.
He goes, if he doesn't hit you
it's cause he has
no passion for you.
- Oh...
- That's always great
when you see--
- I cannot make
Christine believe it.
- (Dan) Broken women like that--
- She just calls it "abuse."
Every time, I'm like,
no, honey...
- (Nikki laughing)
- ...I'm hitting you
'cause I'm passionate
about what you're doing.
This food is cold!
(laughing)
I'm very passionate
about my food being hot.
- Yeah! (laughing)
- I'm passionate about
your culinary skills,
I feel like you're slipping.
- I'm passionate.
What if you have to cook
for a lot of people one day?
- You won't know the timing
of the dishes!
- But I just know
that if I ever get murdered,
my dad is gonna be like,
"She just didn't
gouge his eyes out."
Like, that's gonna be the story.
It's not gonna be like--
- Or-- or while they're
walking him to the court,
in the courtroom, your dad is
gonna stand up and go,
"Did she go for your eyes?"
And he'll go, "She did."
And he's gonna be like,
"I taught her well."
- (Jay) Or it'd be funny if y--
- "Sleep, my angel.
Sleep forever, my angel.
She tried!"
- "Sleep, my angel!"
- In the car accident,
it'd be funny--
in the car accident,
Nikki died
but that guy survived.
And when he went to court--
Nikki's dad went to court
and showed up, and the guy
walked in with the glasses
and the cane...
- (Nikki) Yes!
- And he went-- he went,
"She still got him!"
- Oh my God, that's
a great ending to the story.
- "My baby got him.
My baby got him after all."
- And then he takes 'em off
and he has Jerry Orbach's eyes.
- (laughing)
- 'Cause they were donated
through...
- (hums "Law & Order" theme)
(laughter)
(fire crackling)
- Full track suit.
Can't do it.
Oh, man, can't do it.
There's not a chance.
- Nick Mullen did one yesterday
at The Stand that was impr--
- Shane's all about it,
he said.
- Yeah, I can't--
I couldn't--
Oh, is Christine going
to get soda?
- Well, well,
guess someone
thinks they're better
than everybody.
- Looks like the rats
have fleed the ship.
- Yes, sir, it's what
you think in a track suit.
It's Mafee from TV's "Billions."
- Hi, how are you?
Five dollars...
- 'Cause they're staring at us,
we have to do
a fake kiss now...
- Yeah.
- ...that they're, like,
that they're watching.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wa-- no, you go to the left.
(muffled laughter)
Get him.
(Jay, muffled)
Let go of my shoulder.
Hang on, let go
of my shoulder.
♪♪
(fire crackling)
- Not everybody's watching,
by the way.
But, like, the entire desk
and everyone is watching
which is the best part.
(both laughing)
Dude, I looked over my shoulder
and I see...
if these two were looking,
and the entire desk
was like...
(laughing)
- Oh, that's content.
- I don't know.
For the first time in my life,
I have no idea what to do when
we walk in that door.
- I'll tell you what you do...
(both laughing)
...you're going right
for the elevator.
- And everyone tomorrow
forgets it ever happened.
I didn't think that it's...
- I mean, they got it.
- ...an entire glass window
of everybody...
- Uh, that's why I took the b--
- Holy shit, dude.
Can we blur things?
You guys film
the people inside looking?
Everyone was looking.
- Damn it.
- I went over your shoulder
to take a peek.
- Also, I think
I lost this guy as a fan.
- (laughing)
- He's that kinda guy
where he goes,
"I don't want no queer shit."
- "Yo, fuckin' 'Billions'
into queer shit?"
- Yo... (laughing)
- Dude, everyone's
looking at us.
I don't know what to do, Dan.
- Yeah, let's--
- I wanna go in
a different entrance.
- No, let's just walk in.
- Can we go in
from Del Frisco's?
I hate this.
(laughter)
This is why I would not
be a good impractical joker.
- Yeah.
- I'd be so bad at it
'cause I'm all like,
"Can we leave?!
I wanna leave!"
- Dude, this is great.
- They are unabashedly
staring at us hard.
- Yeah, let's just walk in
and go to the elevator.
We can do it.
- I don't know what to do.
My instinct's to throw you
under the bus completely.
I don't know why.
- Yo...
- That's right, everyone,
it's Dan Soder
from Showtime's "Billions".
- You gonna shoot me in the leg
when the zombies are coming?
- (exhaling) This isn't gonna
make it any better.
(both chuckling)
- That's not gonna make it
any better.
- Def busted.
- You're busted.
- Um...
Come on.
Please don't make me
go to the desk.
- Oh, dude.
- I thought my thing
wasn't working.
- Oh, my God.
You know what I like,
is that dude was just, like,
sitting there staring.
- I mean--
- Like a child of the corn.
(both laughing)
- Hey, hey, 'sup, fellas?
- What's up, buddy?
- Hey, what's up, Jack?
How are you?
- Don't believe what you hear
about us out there.
- Yeah.
We're-- we're straight...
heteronormative men.
- Yeah, you know what?
You're right, just go that way.
- Yeah.
- I say just go that way.
- No? Okay.
We're in trouble.
I knew it.
I knew our love...
Dude, that guy's like,
(deep voice)
"Hey! Hey!
"That's the guy
from 'Billions'.
"What's he doin' out there?
They're probably, like,
filming some behind the s--
Oh, my God!"
- "Queerin' off!"
- "Oh, my--"
- "Oh!"
- "Oh, they're both big!"
- (laughing)
- "So I imagine it's--"
- "What a lumbery kiss!"
- "I mean, I imagine
at some point
it's painful for one
of the two of 'em."
- "One of the grips
has to hurt."
- "I mean, one is giving,
one's receiving.
Maybe they both do?
Is that true love?"
- "You think it's
a real tonsil hockey,
or they're just going
open-mouth?"
- "He's in a sweat suit?"
Did you guys get--
you got it, right?
We're g-- Hi, how are you?
- Hey, sorry you have to wa--
- We're doing a talk show.
- (woman) I-- God,
I feel like I just walked
into a reality show.
- This is how we pitch.
- What's your yearly salary?
It's called "Personal Questions
in the Elevator".
- Not enough.
- How many people
are you seeing currently?
- Yeah.
Are you an organ donor?
- Are you currently cheating?
- This is...
this is the worst elevator
I've ever been on.
- Who should be president?
- No, this was good.
We got a lot--
we got a lot done.
- Is Hannah Gadsby's
special good?
- What is art?
- (laughing)
- Is art...
- Like, personal questions.
Is your clit pierced?
- Yeah.
- Okay. You could say no.
- Would you say your fa--
your relationship
with your father is strong?
(fire crackling)